avec nous dali sanschagrin est ici en
direct et nous sommes bon soir d'aller
vous allez bien oui et avec vous avez
grâce à vous j'avais convaincu fabien
barthez ancien gardien de but vedette
champion de champion du monde en 98
monsieur barthez je situe pour les gens
qui suit - le foot vous êtes comme le
patrick roy européen qui a gagné patrick
roy qui a gagné la coupe stanley qui est
un gardien mythique ici dont vous êtes
un grave alors bonsoir merci d'être là
bonsoir bonsoir fabien merci infiniment
je dois dire que c'est beaucoup joël qui
le comble me bats qui le convaincu
beaucoup qui lui mais qu'il lui a deux
qui lui a demandé d'être des notes merci
beaucoup
alors on est content d'aller chanson
chagrin expliquez moi sur la page
couverture du livre vous êtes accompagné
l'enfant dans sa passion sans perdre la
raison vous avez un enfant vous qui joue
très bien au foot là qu'il ya une une
carrière de jeunes et ça vous est
apparue comme une nécessité de prendre
du recul puis de comprendre le rôle des
parents oui absolument
j'aime ça marque vraiment j'ai eu envie
de d'aider les autres parents qui
cheminait dans le même dans le même
chemin que moi finalement parce que
souvent on n'est pas outillée et les
parents ben on veut bien faire et on
veut bien faire et c'est souvent
l'entourage qui nous qui nous pousse à
devenir un peu fou des fois c'est
vraiment pas de notre faute nous on est
l'on veut que notre enfant joue sa muse
et caetera et la baisse finalement on
rentre dans un petit monde complètement
loufoque où il ya beaucoup de
compétition c'est énorme la rigueur est
omniprésente
les enfants doivent suivre un rythme de
professionnels très très jeune c'est ce
qu'on appelle un peu la spécialisation
précoce si on veut et des poils parent
est vraiment pas préparé souvent le
parent est vraiment beau préparer à sa
première des choses
et deuxièmement ben c'est que tu comment
comment s'en sortir que moi comment bien
la compagnie justement sans devenir
complètement fou parce que des fois ça
peut devenir très oppressant le tour de
france cette pression pour l'enfant et
même pour les parrains pour des défauts
on peut on peut perdre on peut perdre
pied puis joël bats qui est qui a croisé
mon chemin il m'a vraiment en ligne et
pour pour répondre à plusieurs de mes
questions c'est bien fait parce que ses
questions réponses et le parent qui est
à des réflexions des questions joël bats
qui répond mais là fabien barthez est ce
que cette spécialisation précoce le
parfois à 11 9 10 11 ans on demande à
nos enfants de ne faire que du hacker ou
que du foot ou que du baseball est ce qu
est ce qu on ne fait pas fausse
justement partie complètement surtout
surtout à l'âge de 9 ans 10 à roz ar des
gens que cette fausse coûte parce que
leur demande de ceroc que ce sport et on
va dire c'est un portail plus fort que
plusieurs sports qui touche un peu à
tout
comme on dit ce qui va permettre de
développer leur motricité et d'être plus
efficace comme suit derrière
on va dire il va aussi dirigé assez dans
une seule discipline voilà donc moi par
exemple je fais du football on va dire
tous les jours de l'âge de kenza à 36
ans on va dire juste à l'âge de 15 ans
j'avais lu les stations de rugby j'avais
une censure du tennis non je faisais du
foot et du basket je joue à la pétanque
je faisais du vélo on va lire tout ça on
va dire tous ces paramètres on va dire
vous allez retrouver comme vous allez
être on va dire aux autres
professionnels
vous allez retrouver deux donc c'est
important
c'est important pour les petits qui
touche à tous les sports mais les
parents qui vous attendent doivent se
dire oui mais si je veux que mon enfant
à 13 14 15 ans soit choisi pour aller
dans l'élite
il faut que je le spécialiste aux essais
ça l'erreur
mais l'erreur vous le dites vous l'a dit
l'erreur déjà la façon de penser de le
départ si je veux c'est andy qui décide
et c'est lui c'est l'enfant qui décide
peut-être en train de dire si je veux
qu'il allait faire ça c'est un nom si ça
n'est même pas de l'enfant déjà si ça ne
donne pas un gamin on va dire ça
s'appelle la plupart des parents mais de
ça par procuration c'est pas si lieu si
je veux c'est mon âme femme veut c'est
voilà déjà si je veux que mon enfant non
c'est le petit qui doit vraiment décidé
de prendre deux promus direction d'ali
qu'est ce que ça a changé cette
réflexion lada votre rapport avec votre
enfant avec le sport pierre et qu'est ce
que c'est concrètement vous j'avais
changé d'idée à quel sujet à plusieurs
sujets en plus le livre non seulement il
m'a aidé à mieux accompagner mais en
fait ils m'aident à moi aussi dans la
vie il est très chargé
il m'apprend des apprenants à aider mon
garçon mais en fait il m'apprend des
choses pour moi même je suis un exemple
tout bête mais par exemple se prépare et
se préparer la préparation avant les
compétitions
quand tout est correct quand c'est ton
de thon toutes les chaussures sont la
veille ton qui était le la veille ton
passeport il l'avait tout est prêt
mais après de l'esprit que tranquille tu
peux tu éclaté sur le terrain tu peux
être pour ce peut être toi même tu peux
vivre tu peux être libre c'est la même
chose dans n'importe quel travail quand
t'es tu préparé tu vas avoir beaucoup
plus de l'occasion de t'exprimer tout se
soit pas passé agit de ce fait si j'ai
du pain fait c'est donc la concentration
c'est des choses que j'ai appris ce qui
a changé peut-être si oui effectivement
le côté spécialisation précoce
mon garçon à partir de 8 ans y est
rentré dans un but et je mets au dessus
de la cage
beau temps mauvais temps dehors de
verdun ferait un peu fréquent en
vacances sig était en stage donc
peut-être que j'aurais peut-être mis la
[ __ ] douce et pas moi qu'ils
poussaient mais j'aurais [ __ ] même
poussé vers le contrat est en fait il
encore est ce que est ce que ça il est
toujours joui l'on veut oui oui le lait
l'huile il ay est en tunisie en ce
moment sur un autre continent en ce
moment puis bon je me demandais ce qu'il
veut est ce que c'est le bon choix
est-ce que moi chaque jour en tant que
parent de footeux comme on dit dans le
jargon nés de deux parents pour nous tu
es super passionnés on a des questions à
tous tous les jours on se demandait ce
qui prend la bonne la bonne décision
c'est pour ça que vraiment quand j'ai eu
la chance de rencontrer joël bats je
l'accroché là j'ai dit à l'aide gelé
c'était comme un ange gardien qui
volaient j'ai accroché son lg dialed
rapport fabien barthez
à une autre époque quand vous vous avez
eu 11 12 13 14 15 ans est ce que c'est
encore plus difficile aujourd'hui de
garder la tête froide de garder
certaines amour du jeu de jouer non pas
de toujours pour gagner mais de jouer
aujourd'hui parce que je le disais à 16
ans les joueurs peuvent être repêché on
dirait qu un engrenage plus précoce
aujourd'hui non je trouve
on va dire ça tu sais ce qu'est
aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup plus on va
dire aux nombreux deux opus c'est que si
demain les réseaux sociaux la
communication après son ca me prend
beaucoup plus jamais ça tout ça on va
dire ça ans a toujours été ça on va dire
ça comme ça toujours été
qu'est-ce que vous êtes fabien barthez
un jeune là qui veut devenir un jeune de
11 ans qui rêve qui vous écoute là qui
veut devenir joueur préfère qu'elle
quels conseils vous lui donnez premier
conseil premier conseil que je lui
donnant un petit 2 à 12 ans ça va être
travaillé à l'école je devrais les
études c'est le premier conseil que lui
donnent ses lettres on est professionnel
on s'amuse on s'assure de mon premier
conseil ne pas tout mettre sur celui
d'allié conclusion oui bah on en parle
beaucoup d'en livrer justement des
autres avenues t ça c'est un autre point
de pas mettre tout au tout les oeufs
dans le même panier mais j'aimerais
revenir c'est aussi sur ce que fabien
assemat os disait oui je trouve que
c'est plus difficile aujourd'hui hier je
trouve que la pression est plus
plaisante
justement les réseaux faut apprendre aux
jeunes à à faire ses preuves sur le
terrain et pas sur les réseaux donc je
tiens beaucoup plus dangereux que c'est
plus difficile
très bien fabien barthez merci beaucoup
nous avons parlé c'est très apprécié
merci dany dali sanschagrin minuit mi h
et à penser à ce coup ci je pense aller
faire de dollars si c'est une bonne
soirée
armoires dali pas mieux